as the bank holiday begins
and supplies arrive at the cabinet
office mistakenly we were later told two
more mps are now openly questioning the
prime minister
should the prime minister resign of
course he's a great leader the country
is lucky to have it
the government fight back is well
underway this is a pretty typical
question that sums up the mood on mom's
net i'd say
28 mps now want the prime minister to go
this was his response speaking to
mumsnet today if you've lost the trust
of the people and your your government
has lost a trust then you can't possibly
be an effective prime minister i'm not
going to deny that the whole thing
hasn't been a totally
you know
uh
miserable uh experience for
for for
people in in government and totally see
how infuriating it is to think that
people like me uh were not uh fulfilling
the the letter of the of the rules
ourselves i totally understand that
but in tory wimbledon voters have views
on boris johnson
boris johnson is inept
that's all i can say
the conservatives lost most of their
council seats here last month the mp for
wimbledon is a majority of just 600.
has party gate cut through with you guys
yeah i just think it's annoying they
kept lying about it and i just just tell
the truth you can't tell the nation
to be shut down when they don't think
it's important to be shut down it's a
tough job and
it's been difficult
would you vote for the conservatives
definitely not no lib dems yeah
many of the mps that want the prime
minister to go have recently had local
elections they've seen the mood on the
doorstep and it is in lib dem leaning
seats like this in london and the south
east that the tories did particularly
badly and you really don't have to look
far here in wimbledon to find
traditional conservatives turned off by
boris johnson
the mp here has already called for the
prime minister to go but we still don't
know and most tories stand on the idea
of a no-confidence vote if i was a
plotter i'd probably want it to go on
for a while because it allows the
conversations to take place longer the
by-elections on june 23rd in wakefield
in tibetan and hunterton
will be key if i was a boris fan i'd
probably want it as quickly as possible
um to get it out of the way
and when the bunting comes down wavering
mps will be back in westminster things
could change very quickly for boris
johnson